with other social media I'm not sure but
I have no doubt that reddit is improving
my life reddit is hive mind meets
extreme democracy it has the personality
of a single human being but it also
reflects the personalities of millions
of people all around the world the
uniformity of sensibility which can be
seen on the front page where the most
popular links are found becomes much
more amazing when I see that in the last
month
reddit had 90 million nine hundred and
forty six thousand nine hundred and
seventy two unique visitors as Hank
green might say I'm not gonna get my
mind around that
speaking of Hank green and the
vlogbrothers nerdfighteria their online
community is a smaller but analogous
example to the reddit universe
nerdfighteria has its own events like
the project for awesome and its own
eccentricities like Pizza John or
Sharpie face or peanut butter face in
the same way reddit has its own
personality traits like its obsession
with memes video games the ask me
anything feature or explain like I'm
fine it has its own politics right now
for example it's really invested in the
NSA scandal and issues concerning
internet censorship there are things it
hates like improper retik one thing I
discovered this week is that reddit
dislikes the creation of new meme for my
friend's 30th birthday all his friends
came together to make him into a popular
meme it's called the sad Elias meme and
you can find the link for it in the
description and submit anything to it
that you want but when I tried to post
our examples to Reddit I found out that
making memes of pictures that you've
taken is a banner bull offense a banana
bull events in its countless subreddits
communities are more specific and
cultish and like the dark side of tumblr
reddit has its fair share of porn and
nasty shit here's a perfect example of
what I love about red this is a
screenshot I took of an AMA with Lord
starts with Lord answering a question
about her seeming fixation with teeth in
her lyrics and she admits the obsession
but says that she hates dentists and the
first response is a Seinfeld reference
he's just a dentist yeah and you're an
anti dent tight then the second response
is a comedic use of the transitive
property of equality then we have a run
of dentists and teeth related puns in
which Lorde rejoins the conversation
with a pun of her own then someone makes
a teeth and Lord related pun then
someone finds an image of what that pun
describes and then the next person
shares the link to that artists other
work remember the comments aren't
chronological they're based on up votes
which means that the order they appear
in represents what redditors care about
the most in this case clever references
puns fan art and proper attribution my
favorite thing about Reddit is that it's
almost 100% content based though
millions of people contribute to it they
do so anonymously it's not mixed up with
the pathetic local Fame obsessions of
Facebook and Instagram or the much
larger fame obsessions of YouTube
personalities like myself in the social
media war between platforms that
represent social and platforms that
represent media reddit is the purest
representation of the nobler side
yes so you probably want to know why I
haven't posted a video and I don't even
know how many months um Lottery's
laziness disgusted with the form still a
little bit disgusted with it 60 vlog
straight I just was burnt out I had
nothing more to say but mostly I just
wanted to try other things and one of
the things I did try was making music I
just released an EP under my DJ producer
name which is strum stick called new
disguises you can find it on Spotify
SoundCloud iTunes wherever go listen to
it I spent a lot of time and you know
effort on it and I'm proud of it that's
something that I want to explore much
much further